foreign
next up we have Frank calling from New
York City hey Frank welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for having me
thanks for calling how can we help
uh I have a quick I just have a question
about
um College savings I'm at I followed
Dave Ramsey Solutions and I'm right now
at step five basically where I want to
put money into college savings for my
two kids
now my only problem is that I looked at
the past hormone performances of these
um of the 529 plan options they don't
look so good
um can you guys provide some sort of
like a alternative solutions to cost
savings or if not uh or if you guys you
know really you know more going home on
the 529 can you provide everybody some
sort of like a confidence thing because
I don't see any confidence in the uh in
these options and I'm sure I'm not the
only one yeah well we typically
recommend that you start with an
education savings account because they
do have more flexibility in how you
invest your money so it's similar to a
Roth IRA it's funded with post-tax
dollars and that's just a really great
way to start the challenge with that is
that it's got a two thousand dollar a
year limit and it does have some income
limits so 220 000 if you're married a
hundred and ten thousand dollars if
you're single so if you do qualify
though that's a great place to start
because you do have more flexible
investment options and then from there
here we recommend going to the 529 are
you familiar with esas
uh yes I'm familiar with with both Esa
and point 529 it's just that like I said
like you know I'm I'm looking at all
these performances are you looking at
like the past year or two performance
yeah yeah the past 12 months yes well if
that's look at your 401k it's going to
have a very similar sad result it's been
a real down market for a period of time
now uh so I wouldn't let that hold you
back from investing because we look at
this as a long-term play so when are you
going to need this money for college
uh my my son my two kids are
um seven and four right now so probably
in like another 10 to 10 to 13 years you
know give or take
um you know and with that being said I
have a follow-up question if you don't
mind is how do I put money into like so
what I mean by this is should I put a
lump sum into the esa or to the 5.529 or
should I spread it into monthly
installments into the account
I mean do you have a chunk of money
right right now that you're you're
wanting to invest in one of the options
uh well to be honest I do have a roughly
around uh 10K right now now I was I was
thinking about we're doing half half
each one gets half but like like I'm
trying to see if I should put it into
lump sum like put it all in one shot or
should I spread it I mean I think that's
more of a personal preference I I think
if you do a lump sum it's still good to
have a consistent monthly amount that
you're doing over time because it is
easy and tempting to do that 5000 up
front and then kind of forget about it
and then you get in panic mode in high
school so I think it's really about like
you know your discipline and being able
to consistently invest over time yeah
the lump sum will allow more time for
that lump money to grow the other side
is what we call dollar cost averaging
where you're just putting a consistent
amount of money in every single month
and that's also a tried and true
strategy and really what you're trying
to do there we can't time the market we
never recommend that it's all about time
in the market and so either way is great
and Dave Ramsey would say hey if you get
the money go ahead and just put the lump
sum in and forget about it
uh but if that's something where it's a
budget line item for you you can just
invest a portion of that every single
month over 12 months so you can't go
wrong the fact that you're even asking
these questions tells me these kids are
going to go to school debt free but do
not jump off of the roller coaster right
now we're in the middle of the ride and
it's the not fun part of the ride but
give it a year give it two years give it
five years ten years like you mentioned
and you're gonna see that money grow way
more than it would have in a savings
account so that's the key well and so
that's the financial side of things but
with a seven and a four year old the
other thing is to really invest in their
education right now and in their mindset
about college so you know teaching them
about scholarships I know it seems kind
of silly it's early on but even just
starting to talk about college starting
to talk about extracurricular activities
and getting them involved early on can
be helpful I talk to a lot of parents
who you know have Juniors and seniors in
high school and they're like how do we
motivate our kids to do stuff all they
want to do is sit around and play video
games and a lot of times I ask them I'm
like well have they been involved in
activities before now and they're like
like no they they haven't really had a
lot of discipline so it's hard for them
to make that big shift and pivot to now
being like well now we want them to win
scholarships so they need to build a
resume and they need to do all these
things that they haven't been doing over
time oh absolutely but it's like get
your kids active early on start
volunteering as a family and get them
thinking about you know the future it
doesn't need to be some crazy high
pressure over-the-top extra thing but
just get their mindset you know thinking
about their future early on in a way
that's fun and and gets them just
excited and if this is something that
gives you some worry at night get in
touch with one of our smartvestor pros
at ramseysolutions.com they can walk you
through all of the options with esa's
529s and give you some hope and
confidence in that future